okay so the other day on
his podcast joe rogan said something
that he
usually says which is he thinks that
video games are a waste of time
and that it doesn't add to any personal
development the
biggest video gamer in the world ninja
came out
and he basically said that there are a
lot of more
job opportunities in gaming than joe
brogan would think it's not a waste of
time
and a lot of gamers found that got
really mad at you defensive
here's the thing with what the reason
joe says that i don't think joe realizes
you know joe's 52 years old man he's on
the gaming world but
you know video gaming you know guy kids
can do it as a legit career now you're
talking about
there's teams these guys live in houses
uh nba 2k
madden like there's a the gaming world's
so big now people can't make money
but to joe's point you know i don't
think everybody's making you know
how many people play video games more
than anybody playing sports or doing com
there's so many more video games so your
chances i think his point is your chance
of making money doing that are very
small
the other thing why joe says video games
are issues because joe was addicted to
the game i think diablo or diablo
maybe it was crazy he was straight
addicted to it where he's playing you
know when joe gets when it's archery or
where the [ __ ] it is he becomes addicted
to it so for him
i remember i'm wasting time dude joe
used to have to do radio because now
with the jre he doesn't have to but back
in the day you know joe used to come to
kevin and bean quite frequently
and i remember one time this is you know
15 years ago he came in
and he was like telling us off the air i
i would never tell stories out of school
but he was like dude
i didn't get any sleep last night i was
up playing whatever game he's like i had
like 25 [ __ ] diet mountain dews and i
i just lost i just played straight
through the night again with
joseph what are you 51 52 years old he
doesn't
to him like you it's you when i was a
kid i was making money playing video
games for him
he's like dude it can be a complete
waste of time like
you can go professional in it but if
your goal
is to become a comic
a podcaster to your point you get an
actress
you got to do that muay thai jiu jitsu
you got to do that here's the thing not
waste 10 hours and you got to be a
professional gamer you got to spend
10 hours that's that's the the real
problem i think and i and i totally
agree with joe on this one even though i
like gaming and i think
i encourage people to do it if that's
what brings them joy there is a career
path to it the problem is
is that with something like any form of
exercise or something like if you're
really into
uh playing the guitar you may never
become invade malmsteen
but if you spend your free time playing
the guitar there's
a myriad of latent benefits if you i'll
never be andre galvao but if
i spend an hour and a half a couple
times a week doing jiu jitsu
it's going to benefit my life build
relationships in many ways
pushing past self-imposed limitations
understanding uh
uncomfortable situation there's a goal
if you don't make it a career
spending considerable amount of times uh
playing video games
it's not really going to add much and it
can definitely take away 100
that's where i think my thing too is
like if you're spending [ __ ]
10 to 12 hours playing video games when
i was a young man i was trying to meet
girls yeah i was trying to get in shape
it's just it's a dangerous road
also joe is 51 or 50 however he is
52 he's 50 years old let's just say he's
50 plus
joe's 52 years old he doesn't know
[ __ ] video games
he doesn't realize how many people are
making careers and millions and millions
are playing video games and they're
selling out arenas but
to this point how many people in this
entire world are playing video games now
think of your chance
of making it professional in video games
you have a better chance doing it
probably make it to the nba then you do
making millions playing video games
learn to code odds hope i don't get
canceled um uh honestly though like i
heard
from a reliable source that you can get
[ __ ] playing video games now
because of like that see there there he
goes he this guy goes this
who's this who is this ninja oh ninja is
great here you go oh
ninja ninja goes i just wanted to add
joe rogan is a gamer he is
he goes hands down the dude loves him
and is pretty well informed on the
competitive side aspect of it
i just believe there's a huge gap of
last five years where the gaming
has catapulted into different uh era and
would love to explain
he's right and joe should definitely
have ninja on ninja's the biggest gamer
but he's right like in the past five
years it's gotten
so funny with without the weight and the
stitch or what the [ __ ] it called
twitch twitch the only thing that makes
a huge difference
huge the only reason i know is because
my former boss pete visalia
at fox sports left fox sports to be the
head of some gaming
like competition team and we met for
lunch and he was telling me he's like oh
these guys are in the house they're
training
they have a chef they have nutritionists
they work out twice a day i'm like
what the [ __ ] he's like do they have
uniforms like and he's telling me how
much they get paid i'm like holy [ __ ] he
goes
and this is going on all around dude
like it's it's a legit career path
and they did they did they must get laid
if they're rich and have private chefs
and [ __ ]
maybe because okay then i'm sure that
i'm sure ninja's getting his dick i
don't i don't fault a 15 year old boy
for looking at that life and going i
need to do that that needs to be me
because if i got here's the problem big
money and [ __ ] for video games you're
like yes
well here's the problem now my dad like
you're me a loser you're just gonna stay
in your basement all day and play video
games not get outside
and now if i say it to my son he's like
hey dad ninja makes
60 million dollars a year shut the [ __ ]
up like
don't tell me shut up all right have fun
you know i'd go upstairs i'd panic
like they have a like antique my dad's
face with hundred dollars
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected